christian à saint-etienne économistes
bonsoir christian saint-etienne merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur rtl france
alors on l'a vu un vous l'avez entendu
également des plans sociaux s'enchaînent
un peu partout en france c'est le cas
notamment chez aux perches et smart chez
cora enfin un peu partout est ce que
l'état peut actuellement faire quelque
chose pour empêcher ces à plans sociaux
ou est ce que les français vont être
obligés de subir dans les semaines dans
les mois qui arrivent pour être le plus
objectif possible
après avoir rappelé l'échec du début du
confinement puisque si on a confiné
c'est parce que l'état n'était pas prêt
à faire face au virus
il faut dire qu'à partir du mois d'avril
sur le plan économique les principales
mesures nécessaires ont été prises en
france et dans la zone euro comme aux
états unis
donc actuellement l'état pourrait faire
davantage uniquement dans un domaine qui
est celui de l'investissement en fonds
propres dans le secteur productif mais
pour le reste par exemple sur le chômage
partiel
le niveau de prise en charge par l'état
et même trop élevée puisque il ya trop
d'entreprises qui utilisent les rets de
public pour ne pas relancer dans la
production
donc on peut presque regretter que
l'état soit aussi aussi généreux pour
l'instant à des milliers d'emplois sont
menacés certains en sont même déjà
supprimé est-ce que des désirs des
études existent aujourd'hui pour savoir
combien de temps cette situation va
durer et surtout combien de temps
va-t-il falloir pour sortir la tête de
l'eau
si vous voulez la l'économie française
va baisser de l'ordre de 9 à 10 points
de pips et thales s'est jamais vu une
amende depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale
n'essaie pas seulement une crise
économique et l'accélération d'une
mutation totale qui a démarré il ya une
quinzaine d'années
et s'accélérer après très fortement qui
est la mutation de la numérisation
robotisation de l'économie dans
mutations dans laquelle la france a pris
pas mal de retard et donc dans ce
contexte on se retrouve dans une
situation où il faut restructurer
l'économie
et quand on dit que l'économie va
baisser de 10% c'est pas tout l'économie
qu'il avait 7 10 portant vous avez 15 %
des entreprises qui vont disparaître ou
se restructurer et vous allez avoir 30%
des entreprises qui vont qu'ils vont
boom et donc la question centrale pour
l'état c'est d'accélérer ces aides
notamment en fonds propres et en fonds
de recherche et développement dans les
filières en forme en fort développement
ça le point central est pour l'instant
l'état a pris des mesures de soutien de
l'activité mais n'a pas pris
suffisamment de mesures stratégiques
pour la reconfiguration de l'économie on
peut s'attendre à ce qu'il le fasse
fin août début septembre il faudra
prendre des mesures très fortes pour
éviter que le chômage partiel d'une part
et que le chômage structurel qui va se
développer ne dure trop longtemps en
fait il va falloir reformé ma fille
demande et les employés pour les
nouvelles technologies et les nouvelles
activités qui apparaissent dans la
nouvelle économie vous parlais justement
de rose structuration de l'économie de
et de l'urgence de
de prendre des décisions quelles vont
être les décisions importantes à prendre
très rapidement l'a dit si vous lisiez à
la fin du la fin du mois d'août début
septembre
oui alors d'abord il faut absolument
identifier les principales filières clés
dans lesquels la france de se développer
nous avons trop baissé dans dance tout
ce qui est numérique quand on a par
exemple vendu alcatel à nokia
ils auraient au contraire salué des sept
entreprises à se relever puisqu'elle
avait une certaine avancée sur la 4g
il fallait continuer d'investir
massivement dans ce domaine il faudrait
il faut investir massivement dans
l'appareil de défense il faut renforcer
l'état régalien et de manière générale
il faut investir dans toutes les
technologies numériques
tout ce qui a trait à la
microélectronique et dans ces domaines
là depuis depuis 7-8 ans l'état ne s'est
pas assez donc il faut avoir une vraie
politique industrielle de robin
anisation de l'industrie française il
faut également s'appuyer sur les grands
acteurs du tourisme et de la
construction que nous avons en france
dans le cadre d'un plan de retrait
location massive des infrastructures
donc il ya tout un travail d' état
stratège à faire en urgence pour
relancer l'économie sur un sentier de
croissance très dynamique
merci beaucoup question saint-etienne
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur arte
france
elle rappelle que vous êtes économiste
merci beaucoup